Most days,
...a lot of you don't hear too much about us.
- Some days, these days, holidays,
you might hear about maybe a handful of us.
The first of us.
- [Announcer:] For the first time in WNBA history
someone has dunked!
- [Cheering]
- The only.
To win that title.
Take that job.
Run that fast.
That far.
These are luminaries in their own right,
indisputably deserving the spotlight.
But let's tell the rest of the story too:
how over-fixation on firsts
to the exclusion of everything else can erase history,
blot out the experiences of so many
who were, who are held back.
How hyping just the same few names
can feed scripts that pit women against each other,
as if there were only so much attention to go around.
But girls, women and allies
always have come together to make collective impacts
and to make history.
Protesting police brutality
and systemic racism.
Advocating to end policies that punish protest.
Sitting out whole seasons
to focus on social justice.
- [Cheering and clapping]
- Getting out to vote
and winning political seats as well.
And when one win sparks more?
That ignites a radiance uncontained by any spotlight.
We are speaking out against discrimination,
violence, objectification.
We are fighting for representation,
equal pay and parental leave protection.
We have been fighting period poverty,
public health crises
and the crisis of
missing and murdered Indigenous women.
Most days,
a lot of you don't hear too much about us.
But as Women’s History Month comes to a close,
we’re here to remind you:
It’s not just one month or one day.
It’s every day.
It’s not just the few.
It’s all of us.
We ignite a radiance uncontained by any spotlight.
You're in its presence right now.